welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of brick
and Morty season 7 episode 7 wet quat
American Summer a play on the David
Wayne comedy Wet Hot American Summer a
title that this episode has very little
to do with thematically other than it
being all about I guess teens wanting to
get laid but hey it is the very first
episode of Rick and Morty to use summer
in an episode title let's break down
this quat taken episode shot by shot for
all the Easter eggs hidden animation
details and inside jokes that you might
have missed okay we open on summer doing
chores for Rick she watches bunch of
random Gunk off of his car we see some
green Gunk with hair and then some
purple Gunk with a tentacle so this is
just some giant creature that Rick flew
through and got some of his hair on it
too then she sorts amulets into the
cursed and normal bins a demon pops out
of one of the cursed ones and then she
has to read a spell from an ancient book
to make it disappear and I like how this
demon has mummy wrappings on it we are
reminded of Summer's time with Rick and
something ricked this way comes with the
Satan likee Mr needful in the Occult
Store of cursed artifacts and yeah that
is another episode in which summer just
gets super buff then summer has to
butcher an alien bug in the backyard and
she gets a spray of purple guts in the
face and then she cleans the memory
chamber that we saw in the Mor's
mindblowers episode remember she does
know about this room because Rick had
her open the emergency cabinet to save
them the smashed vials on the ground
include three red ones those are for
Rick screw-ups the five blue ones which
are for Morty screwups and then three
purple ones which are for the full
family summer tells Rick to pay up and
Rick asks summer didn't I just upgrade
your ponytail yes Summer's ponytail
upgrade we'll come back again and again
this episode he also refers to some
ghost goggles that would be in the
vending machine but summer asks for an
attribute slider this is a feature that
you would see in an RPG to tweak your
character's skills and appearance she
asks for strength so that she can
impress a frisbee golf party or frol
Rick UPS her strength but that reduces
her intelligence more than it reduces
her Charisma and dexterity like strength
and intelligence are at opposite ends of
the stat Spectrum the most mutually
exclusive strength Charisma dexterity
and intelligence are stats that you
would see in RPG and not to be gross
about this but literally anytime Rick
and Morty artists make a character buff
they always draw in the gutters you know
what I mean ah can't unse those I wish
the story Train episode wouldn't have
put that term in my head he he's he's
got those things what do you call them
the um B gutters Mor Morty brings up
that he helped Rick kill his Nemesis
referring of course to the death of Rick
Prime two episodes back I think it's
really interesting how this season seems
to be taking steps each episode even in
the silly side ones to make them all
have some kind of canonical link maybe
to out any viewers who claim that some
episodes of the series are non-canon
skippable ones so here we get a call
back to UNM ricken along with the kuato
call back to unor ricking because Rick
Prime had one of those and also the post
credit scene of last episode Rick F in
your Mort has Morty greeting Jimmy in
the school hallway and Jimmy says see
you at the frol mixer tomorrow so they
are really aiming for Episode by episode
continuity in ways that they haven't
always done in past Seasons Rick throws
a ninja smoke bomb to vanish but he
really just teleported into the bag of
trash at somewh brought up from the
basement
you just hide anywhere huh yeah Rick
loves doing this kind of move like when
he pretended to turn into snakes in the
G Swifty episode now this frol party has
a poster and a banner that read May the
course be with you just the lamest most
forced Star Wars reference because I
guess you need a course to play frol but
I do have to say they're not entirely
they just really love frol and
they don't like people who fake loving
frol Trisha returns that's a longtime
School mate who most notably dated Ethan
in the worldly early conspiracy episode
and has been in a bunch of episodes of
Rick and Morty summer I want to your dad
oh really remember worldly durly
conspiracy was another episode where
summer bizarrely changed her appearance
to try to win people over Brad returns
along with Jimmy and Jimmy is really
into summer rolling a quarter across her
fingers her dexterity is wild and again
it's just all about the frol because as
a frer he would be most impressed with
just someone having dexterity with their
fingers and he even says even consider a
bigger disc which at first sounds like a
sexual advance but no it's not he's just
trying to recruit for his frol team and
then the snack table outside has a
banner that says ultimate snacks because
when you're someone who loves frol and
Ultimate Frisbee the snacks are ultimate
and beside that table is Nancy you
remember her that's Summer's former
friend from band who joined them in the
side quest for Rickie business and I
like that she's just at the party too
Morty Taps a slider to up Summer's
intelligence and then he puts it on to
up his strength and again do the gutters
and I love how they always say stupid
nonsensical nothing jokes when they get
buffed like let's see if these abs are
waterproof that statement means nothing
but it's also the kind of that
some brosie meat might just say with
confidence and zero irony and it just
works for them yes as you can see I have
um clearly moved on from my youth summer
sees a bunch of floating numbers and
equations beautiful mind but if you
actually do the math on these it adds up
like the knife hitting the clock and
then falling into the fruit bowl with
Nega 9.81 m/s squared which in physics
is any object's acceleration due to
gravity so she uses all this to create
this rub gold bergian chain reaction
that trips Morty with the skateboard and
really the smartest thing about it is it
is a frol move that really impresses
Jimmy and Brad I just can't get enough
of how much this episode Champions frol
it doesn't make fun of frol Summer and
Morty come out of the pool merged with
Morty loded into her midsection becoming
a quat that's a creepy psychic twin from
Total Recall which makes primar having
won an UNM ricken not just a throwa away
joke but a setup for a plot turn later
this season Morty says open your mind
which is a quote from the OG cuad in
total rickall open your
mind but we learn that he's also
desperately trying to psychically
connect with Summer every time he says
this Rick is back home watching a show
called cake or fake on interdimensional
cable it's a parody of the Netflix show
is it cake but in this version It's
humans that might be cake instead of
inanimate objects the contestant appears
to be a guier like character with a
flame shirt and cargo shorts frosted
tips which does remind me of the best
meme of all time with Paul Hollywood the
judge of the Great British baking show
or bake off if you're in the UK being
speculated to be the British twin of
guary who are separated at Birth in a
Parent Trap scenario and we see this
trap guy screaming do I not breathe do I
why not speed if you prick us do we not
bleed if you tickle us do we not laugh
but later Rick says the sentient cakes
keep you guessing so in a sense this
show is like a cake Turing test summer
feeds rats with eight legs to the
carnivorous plants and then swipes
through her photos from the night before
we see a selfie with Trisha and then a
photo of her flexing with susum got SW
SW and then Brad posting quat stin IRL
and this leads to a targeted ad for a
quat mind openers club that summer got
because she thinks the algorithm is
being affected by Morty saying open your
mind but really it's because she chose
to linger for a second longer on Brad's
quat related post which is a really
really clever detail because yeah it's
easy to think that like these apps are
listening to us and then affecting the
targeted ads we get but really it's more
about how long we engage with certain
post as we swipe through them like it is
so exact if you just hold a post for a
microc second longer it'll know that
your wife's pregnant and I I swear meta
isn't pain me to say this lots of games
let you command one character or even a
small team but if you want to command a
full Fleet then you got to play Star
Trek Fleet command Star Trek Fleet
command is an open world freeo play 4X
MMO set in the Star Trek universe you
take charge of legendary characters and
iconic ships from over 50 years of Star
Trek and send them on missions of
exploration to expand your territory got
to obey the prime directive but beyond
that the universe is your oyster it's up
to you whether to battle other players
in strategic space combat or to
negotiate alliances upgrade your ships
by harvesting resources and you'll have
even more options for how to navigate
the final frontier Star Trek Fleet
command adds new content every month so
you'll never run out of stuff to do if
you're a new player you can use the code
warp speed to get 10 epic shards for
Captain James T Kirk Kirk he's as
powerful in the game as he is legendary
in real life buffing any ship he's on
Star Trek Fleet command is available on
both desktop and mobile and is
celebrating its 5year anniversary this
month if you've never played now is the
perfect time to start just click the
link in the description we also see that
Trisha posted a how it started how it's
going meme of Summer and her handle is
at trishy Queen so summer goes to mind
openers which looks like it's on the
same Planet as blips and chits and I'm
just basing that because those guys in
the arcade by the Roy lifeo lived game
seem to be on the sidewalk out front
Morty says open your mind the bartender
and apparently that is the name of a
cocktail in this bar which makes sense
she meets kawhai who is named after the
Hawaiian island kawhai and you know what
this guy can we all just stop taking
things from Hawaii right now they've had
a really rough year actually this dude
was previously sitting in the booth
behind summer when she got her drink and
was totally staring at her from the
moment she sat down I'm not 100% certain
but I think he is voiced by Glenn Powell
Who is credited on this episode Glen
Powell of course the breakout star of
Top Gun Maverick who's having a moment
with anyone but you between him and Hugh
Jackman it just blows my mind the voice
actors they can get on the show he
invites her to join the other VIP quats
you should come hang open your mind
sounds like we're down to clown yeah it
seems like cuad Morty in that moment was
putting his hands up to warn her so
upstairs they meet Kenneth a sexy Jesus
looking guy which is the kind of look
that wew work founder Adam Newman and
nium cult leader Keith reri we're going
for later he says he's a revolutionary
and there's nothing more revolutionary
than me being rich which is exactly what
cult leaders and disruptors are all
about and yeah this episode takes a dark
turn here as these episodes always do
into a taken scenario summer gets
kidnapped and drugged and wakes up in a
morg headed toward a furnace and then
activates the ponytail implant that Rick
put in there with the phrase I don't
give my grandpa enough credit the doctor
laughs saying the oven's mostly for
bodies but I make pizzas in here too I
don't know why he says this but it's so
funny why is he saying this to her why
is he so proud of it but summer saves
this woman and this is a woman who
flirted with her as she the club and the
woman she will end up with at the end of
the episode Beth asks Rick to find the
kids Rick checks Morty's mindblowers
memory room it's all cleaned up after
Summer's chores in the foreground we
actually see a bunch of labels on these
vials from left to right we see fear of
something then pocket poo then time
something hot balls Stanford probably
Stanford Prison Experiment related first
something then virginity and that one's
red so it's Rick's virginity a Morty one
labeled micro and then a rick one
labeled something LOL Rick's AI plays
back the security footage footage in
black and white which the AI did for
dramatic effect because of course Rick's
Tech would be more advanced and have the
footage in color the AI reminds him that
she is the voice of Rick's dead white
Diane back at the bar we see kaai is
shatting up another girl with a quad
giving her the same speech he gave
summer he confesses that Morty is at the
taken house overtly calling out that
this episode is now based on the Liam e
movie Morty is being held in room 237
this is the room in stainley Kubrick's
The Shining where Danny and Jack meet
the naked ghost lady room 237 is also
the title of a fantastic documentary
about conspiracy theories around The
Shining Kenneth confesses that he
profits by transplanting quat onto
wealthy buyers who want quat's status
symbols Rick follows the path of Liam
NES from Taken beating up the taxi
driver then the bartender then the
kidnapper and then the other trafficker
and Rick tells her that open your mind
is really a directive for summer to
communicate with her quato with a
psychic link and summer does this
finding herself in a liquidy black void
that looks like the upside down in
stranger things and also kind of like
the black room in Under the Skin Morty
is at an auction like the daughter in
taken that she ends up in the host wears
this mask and there's a few guys who are
just just running the auction online
Kenneth orders that kawhai be killed and
they pop his and his kuat's heads with a
high-pitch tone like the David
Cronenberg classic scanners Rick folson
with a noise maker on his Temple which
she must wear all the time just in case
this ever comes up Summer uses her frol
skills to take down the auction host
they kick open a door to find this
massive quat and Rick wonders whose
chest would be that big like in the
finale of Taken The Showdown happens on
a huge yacht Rick jumps out of the
window inflating his butt to cushion the
fall and Rick now says something really
interesting he tells summer that he
considers Morty like a dog but summer
like a cat for whom affection is earned
and Rick treats her more like an equal
because he respects her and she reminds
him of her grandmother a huge admission
Rick Sees In Summer qualities of his
wife Diane so Rick activates Summer's
ponytail secret move which goes down the
guy's throat to kill him which kind of
reminds me of the hair-based fatalities
done by the Mortal Kombat character
cindel they board the yacht kuad Morty
escapes his sedation Kenneth gets
cornered there are days and there are
days which does Echo the punchline from
this Mr show sketch where a kidnapper
cuts off his own toe there there are
days and there are days Kenneth quat
splits off and pushes out his own quat
The Mastermind behind it all quat Morty
drops him from the Skylight and wrestles
quatu quat Kenneth and Rick steps on
help but I just love how summer
wordlessly stops him and shakes her head
like dude don't don't get involved in
this quat quat Kenneth pulls out a knife
and it's got its own quat knife a third
layer of quat pops out the voice is just
getting higher and higher pitched each
time and all just leads to this extended
flat choke where Morty wants a spider
chair but Rick can't jiggle it hard
enough to shake Kenneth's corpse out of
it and Rick says he the remote for
motion smoothing which feels like a joke
about TV interlacing settings that
condense the frame rate to create that
annoying so oper effect that we have to
turn off when we get new TVs or when we
visit our parents so essentially Rick
turns off motion smoothing to give the
chair a more staggered frame rate that
allows him to shake those quatos loose
back at school we find ourselves in a
Rudy scenario with guat Morty making the
big game finishing move catching the FR
all Frisbee and dunking it in a large
Golf Hall in The End Zone it also kind
of looks like it was rugby related cuz
it looks like they were in the middle of
like that kind of rugby huddle and Brad
says yeah Morty that's a par the post
grit scene shows the wealthy buyers
Kenneth's intended clients golden animal
masks yes a reference to the VIPs in
Squid game the fat one says that he paid
69 fluro referring to the alien currency
in the Rick and Morty Universe
referenced in Morty night run these guys
love joking about 69 but when one of
them uses it in a wholesome honest
context about 69 and his white it just
grosses them out thanks for watching
this breakdown the best way to support
new rockstars is to grab some great
merch options From Nerd rot. shop you
can follow me on all social platforms at
eaos subscribe to all three channels in
the new Rockstar Network big thanks to
Jordan Morris for helping write this
breakdown thanks for watching I'll see
you next time
[Music]
bye